- Samuel L. Jackson, where are you?
(audience cheers)
(Denzel whoops)
Samuel L. Jackson.
(chuckles) Nah, I'm not gonna do that.
Let me tell you something.
We go back so far, but
I'll start with this,
152 movie titles,
I got IMDb Pro.
(audience laughs)
152 movie titles,
27 billion in box office.
27 billion,
more than any other actor in history,
(audience cheers)
Samuel L. Jackson.
11 times, Nick Fury.
One time, Django.
I just like saying Django
'cause he says Django,
I just like Django.
Sam and I go back in the theater,
the Goodman Theater.
We worked together even before that
at the Negro Ensemble Company,
we did a pretty good play
called "A Soldier's Play,"
that became a great movie,
"A Soldier's Story."
Wasn't as good as it would've
been had Sam been in it,
but that's for another day. (laughs)
That's for another day.
What else I got on here?
(audience laughs)
Many awards, obviously.
Big box office, you know all about that.
Here's what you don't know.
These are, and there's a few of them,
the organizations that Samuel L. Jackson
and his wife, LaTanya Jackson, give to:
Alzheimer's Association, American
Institute for Stuttering,
American Red Cross, Artists
for a New South Africa,
Bedford-Stuyvesant
Restoration Corporation,
Black Economic Alliance,
The Brain Trust, Cedars-Sinai,
Broadway Cares/Equity Fights AIDS,
Carousel of Hope, Children's Defense Fund,
Desmond and, and somebody
Tutu Legacy Foundation,
Earth Island Foundation,
the HollyRod Foundation for
Autism and Parkinson's Disease,
In a Perfect World Foundation,
The Joseph Lowery Institute
for Social Change,
Magic Johnson Foundation, Spelman College,
Morehouse College, NAACP
Legal Defense Fund,
National Action Network,
Kidney Foundation, Solutions Coalition,
the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History,
Spelman College United Nero College Fund,
and the Urban League.
(audience cheers)
That's what he's been doing,
I don't know what y'all been doing.
(audience laughs)
But that's what he's been doing.
Make sure I didn't forget anything now.
Oh, I'm supposed to look up here.
Now,
now let's look over just a
few of his greatest moments.